(piano music)
- So I've talked on this channel before
about how I think there
are a lot of parallels
between video games and real life.
In a video game,
as your character
progresses through the game
and you upgrade your stats
and make more money,
you're able to unlock better equipment,
new and more powerful abilities.
And travel to different
and more exciting parts of the map.
And life kind of works
in the exact same way.
As you develop marketable skills
and improve yourself,
your options in life open up.
Our entire society seems to operate
on a competence hierarchy.
The people who get the most attention,
the most money,
and have the most opportunity in life,
tend to, not always,
but tend to be very,
very good at something.
But everyone kind of knows this
whether instinctually
or by societal conditioning.
So I'm not really saying
anything new like,
"Oh, if you wanna get better at life
"and be successful,
"then stop playing so many video games
"and spending so much time
"upgrading your video game character,
"and start upgrading your
real life character."
While that may be true,
there's a glaring issue
with that whole approach.
And it's that
unlike video games,
upgrading your skills
and getting so good at things
to the point where people start paying you
lots of money,
and you reach the upper
echelons of society,
if that's what you want to do anyways,
it's really hard to do.
And it takes a lot of time.
Years and years and years,
sometimes even decades.
So people don't bother doing it.
Pretty much everybody
knows exactly what it will take
to become successful,
but it's just so difficult to do it
that we distract ourselves with TV
and video games
and whatever other vice that we have.
So we stay in a bad situation
or a lower paying job
or whatever our undesirable
present conundrum is.
But thankfully,
I think there's an answer
to this problem.
I think we can analyze video games
and try to figure out
what makes them so compelling.
Why is it so fun to level up
our in game character?
And can we leverage that
and apply that same approach
to real life?
But in order to answer
that question more accurately,
we need to dive into video games
and figure out what video games
are doing better
than real life.
(piano music)
Video games have better clarity
of objectives.
Say in "Rune Scape"
if you're level one attack,
you can only wheel the
bronze or iron sword.
And if you try to pick up a steel sword,
it won't let you.
It says you need level five attack.
So all you got to do is slash up goblins
for like half an hour,
and you can achieve level five.
Even when you talk to a
random NPC in "Skyrim"
and he wants you to go do something,
whatever he said
automatically gets updated to a quest log.
And if you were to Wikipedia that quest,
it would tell you
exactly what reward you stand to gain
from completing it
and what exact steps you need to do
to complete that quest.
While the possibilities
for what you can do in a video game
may not be as extensive
as they are in real life,
the objectives are certainly more clear.
We know exactly what we need to do
in a video game
most of the time,
unless it's a puzzle game
and you like that kind of thing.
You usually have a backlog
of things you need to do.
And all the little steps
you need to get there
are broken down into
little tiny baby steps
that will ensue towards your goal.
In real life though,
you're kind of born to a random family,
in a random part of the map,
you have a random race
and a random socioeconomic class.
And as far as you know,
you didn't even agree
to play the game.
You didn't even know
you were playing the game
until you gained some
sort of mental autonomy.
You're kind of like,
"Okay, I'm here now.
"And my dad does this for a living.
"And I have two siblings
"and blahbity, blahbity, blah."
You're not really given
a clear cut tutorial
as to what to do
or what the point of the game is.
You kind of just arrived
and are expected to figure it out.
The people around you
espouse vague sentiments like,
"Get a good job.
"Find a good wife.
"Settle down and have a nice house."
And all of these things are great,
but they definitely lack the clarity
that a video game gives you.
And the vagueness of it all
definitely leads a lot of people
to have analysis paralysis,
or not know exactly what
they wanna do in life
because there's so many options,
they can't pick one.
They're afraid if they go on a path,
it's not gonna be the right one.
So video games definitely
have more clear objectives
that help you do stuff.
Another big one is difficulty.
Video games are way easier than real life.
Physically, all it asks of you
is to move your fingers a little bit
and hit some plastic
every once in a while.
All you're doing
is kind of tricking your monkey brain
into thinking that
you're achieving things.
But in reality,
you're just sitting there.
So physically,
it's extremely easy.
And the time commitment
is usually way lower.
In "The Sims"
if you wanna become a master chef,
then it only takes like what?
A couple of weeks in game
or something like that,
which really translates
to a couple of hours of playing.
But in real life,
if you wanna become a master chef,
it takes an entire lifetime.
And not only that,
you have to be interested in it.
You have to be willing
to sacrifice friendships and other things
in order to pursue that goal
over years and years
and decades.
- Roll the (beep) pizza dough.
- [Man] Here's more mozzarella.
What are you doing?
- You wanna find a wife in "The Sims"
all you have to do
is look around for the first girl
that you see
that's kind of this
relatively same age as you
and you woo her.
Spam the flirt options
until her attracted to you bar goes up?
Anyways, there's literally a bar
that tells you how into you she is.
And as soon as that bar hits the end
or it max's out,
you can pop her the question
and then you have a wife.
And that can take like 15 minutes to do.
In real life though,
if you wanna find a spouse,
you got to clean yourself up a bit.
You have to be somewhat respectable.
You got to go out
and meet new people
and put yourself in
uncomfortable situations.
You have to be bold and courageous
to ask people out
and ask them on a date.
And you need to show up to that date.
You need to be on time for that date.
You need to be engaged
and listen.
You need to ask difficult questions.
You need to see if that person
is actually somewhat like you,
or if you guys can relate.
And maybe that will lead to
a couple more dates.
And it might work out in heartbreak
because you really liked that girl
and she didn't like you back.
Or maybe she really liked you
and you didn't really like her,
and you had to tell her the hard truth
that you're just not into her.
There's a lot of emotional stakes
and uncomfortable situations
that go into dating
and potentially finding a spouse.
And a lot of the time
that whole process
can take several iterations.
You can be going on dates
for years and years
and decades even.
And you might never even find a spouse.
Who knows?
It's not math.
It's not like in video games
where there's a little algorithm
you have to follow
or you do a little Wikipedia search
for something.
Life is just way harder than video games.
Even if you look at something so simple
as getting jacked,
getting big and muscular at the gym.
In real life,
it's actually pretty simple.
Eat lots of protein,
around a gram per pound of body weight.
You need to go to the gym
and lift more weight
than you did last time.
You got to do that
over and over and over again
until you're just a huge human being.
But in most video games,
your characters usually just come
prebuilt jacked.
You're just a super muscular guy
right off the get-go,
and you don't even need to workout
to maintain it.
It's amazing.
- [Man] It's my ideal form.
I'm just freaking jacked
and I'm yoked.
- So let's talk about risk,
not the board game,
but the concept of risk.
In real life,
everything is kind of a risk.
In the pursuit of wealth,
you risk going bankrupt.
In the pursuit of intimacy,
we risk rejection.
In the pursuit of a particular degree,
you risk the chance
that you picked the wrong one.
You risk years of hating
whatever you picked.
But in video games,
there's basically no risk.
You risk losing gold
and supplies, I guess,
that don't really exist.
But ultimately, you don't get to feel
the stabs, the hacks and the slashes
inflicted upon your end game character.
If you die,
you just respond.
If your team gets squad wiped,
you just play another round.
In video games,
you get all of the reward
with none of the risk.
So video games have clearer objectives.
They are easier to do.
And there's basically no risk involved.
Then what's stopping us from spending
just all of our time in video games
and giving up on this whole life thing
and just spending all of our time
playing "Minecraft"
Well, I think it's in this final category
where life really takes the lead.
And that is the category of rewards.
(upbeat music)
It's nice to get a little dopamine rush
when you get a headshot
or a squad wipe or a win
or unlocking that new armor
or that special knife.
But it only feels good
while you're playing the game.
Video game rewards are what I would call,
superficial rewards.
They're instantly gratifying,
kind of like a donut.
They're sweet
and they're colorful on the surface,
but hollow
and nutritionally useless at its core.
At their core?
At their core.
And if all you eat is donuts,
you will gradually decay
and become ill
on a long enough timeline.
Video game rewards are fun,
but they do virtually nothing
to increase your baseline
sense of fulfillment.
Whereas rewards in real life,
both have a higher ceiling
and are deeper and longer lasting.
You don't need me to tell you
that there's kind of a difference
in the reward you get
from unlocking a new
helmet in a video game
versus the rewards you get
for being a good father
and raising a family
and instilling good
values into your children.
Getting a squad wipe
is really fun in the moment,
but it pales in comparison
to the type of satisfaction
that living a life
that you're proud of gives you.
Being somebody that you admire.
Living your life in a way that,
if you were viewing yourself
from the third person,
you'd say, "Hey, that
guy's a really cool guy."
Being that person offers
you a satisfaction
that video game rewards
just can't give you.
Life offers you the opportunity
to make something of yourself
so you can contribute
to the world around you.
And that feels good on
an existential level,
not just on a little brain chemical level.
So that's kind of enough of that
Sunday school sermon.
How do we make real life
into a video game?
How do we leech all of the power
and the compelling nature of video games
and apply it to real life?
Well, I have a couple ideas.
Well, a few ideas.
A couple is two.
A few is more than three?
Three or more?
I have a few ideas,
several ideas even.
Step one is to get clearer objectives.
You have to treat the goals in your life
like a quest log
in a video game.
You have to clearly define
what your goal is
and what the steps you need to take
to get there are.
And then you need to clearly define
the reward that you stand to gain
for achieving that thing.
If you don't have that roadmap,
then you can't really guarantee
that your brain can fully understand
what's at stake.
It's just gonna become
another vague sentiment
that gets brushed under the rug
and you ignore for your whole life.
So if something is important to you,
write it down.
Write exactly what it is
that you need to achieve.
And write down every single little step
you need to take to get there
as efficiently as possible.
And then you can get yourself
emotionally excited about it.
There's a reason why you want
the things that you want.
It's because
you stand to gain so much from it.
But unless you clearly define it,
you're going to forget it.
And once you create a roadmap
of all of the quests you have on cue,
you could really benefit from reducing
the difficulty.
Video games are extremely easy.
Life is hard.
But it doesn't have to be that way.
You can break down these quests
into the smallest possible daily action
that will propel you towards your goal.
If your goal is to write a book,
and you've always wanted to write a book,
you wanna to become an author,
then break down that thing, that goal,
into this smallest possible daily habit
that you're actually likely to do.
And that's probably something like
write 100 words a day.
And that might be so insultingly low,
you'll think to yourself,
"Wow, I'll never achieve
"the goal of writing a book.
"100 words. That's nothing."
But if you usually do zero words,
that's infinitely more than zero.
I think that's math.
I was about to say
it's 100 times more than zero.
But that's just 100% not true.
If you want to learn guitar,
if you wanna be very good at guitar,
but you never practice,
then download a habit tracker
and make "practice 15 minutes of guitar"
I don't know how many quotations I need,
a daily habit
that you do every single day.
And you might think to yourself,
"Wow, 15 minutes?
"Everybody that I know
"who's very good at guitar
"practices for at least an hour a day."
Well, you don't.
And you need to get in the habit
and get really good at practicing
15 minutes a day
over the period of months
before you upgrade to 20 minutes,
30 minutes,
40 minutes even.
So the next thing
is for things that remain difficult
no matter what.
Not everything can be broken down
into a tiny little habit
that you take action on every single day.
Some things are just acutely difficult
and you have to deal with them.
So there's a weird phenomenon
I've noticed throughout my whole life.
And that is
that you can game-ify resistance.
There's power to be absorbed
from the feeling of resistance.
If you've ever gone cliff jumping,
then you know this feeling really well.
All your friends are jumping off
of this 30 foot cliff into the water.
They're having such a good time time.
And it's your turn.
And you hate Heights.
As you step onto that ledge,
there's a feeling in your gut.
It's like this tight knot.
All of your survival instincts
are telling you not to jump.
There is like a wall,
a palpable wall of resistance
stopping you from taking that leap.
But if you've ever taken that leap before,
you know that the second
your foot leaves that ledge,
you ignore the resistance anyways.
There's almost a euphoria
that overwhelms you
as you jump over the cliff
and you plunge into that icy cold water.
You feel alive and invigorated.
You feel incredible and powerful.
It's because you absorbed
the power of that resistance.
You devoured it.
And this applies to pretty much
everything in life
where there is a significant amount
of internal resistance.
When you overcome resistance,
you absorb its power.
And the greater the resistance,
the greater the power.
And understanding this truth
can really change the way
that you see the world.
Instead of seeing it as a bad thing
that the rewards in life
are hidden behind discomfort paywalls,
you'll view it as a good thing.
You'll see these pockets of discomfort
as power-ups
that you can absorb on demand.
They're lying around everywhere
for you in life.
Asking a girl out,
there'll be a wall of discomfort there.
But overcoming that wall
offers you the power,
regardless of the response.
She could reject you or whatever,
but it doesn't take away the fact
that you overcame discomfort
and you have become somebody
who is better at overcoming discomfort.
And that is a tangible,
powerful feeling to have.
And it's a power that sticks with you.
So game-ify discomfort.
And another way to game-ify real life
is to embrace risk.
If you become a risk taker,
somebody who's more comfortable with risk,
you'll gain the strength
to bear life's pain.
Realize that by not taking risks in life,
you're not saving yourself from pain.
All you're doing is trading away
the acute discomfort of action
for the slow burning longer lasting decay
of inaction,
where feelings like
despair and regret blossom.
So how is that any less painful?
And the final thing
is just to remind yourself
and reflect on the rewards
that life has to offer.
You're allowed to get excited
about being the person
that you want to be.
Achieving something
you've always wanted to achieve.
And I think it's important
that we reflect on these
potential rewards often.
Otherwise, our daily grind can kind of
get so monotonous
it feels pointless.
One reward that I'm currently aspiring
to achieve right now
is less of a tangible physical reward,
but more of a feeling.
The feeling of sort of calm
and peacefulness
and tranquility.
And I want to invite that feeling
into my life
as much as possible.
I'm going camping this weekend
so I'm really looking forward
to just letting all of the worries of life
(beep) off for a bit
so that I can just be
at peace with myself.
And I know for a fact
that's a feeling that video games
can't really give me.
There's a reason why
people play video games.
They're super fun.
They're super compelling.
But the video game rewards
pale in comparison to
the type of rewards
that life can give you
when it starts going your way.
And if it feels like it's been a while
since it's been going your way,
I hope at least that this video
has given you some ideas
you can sink your teeth into
so you start feeling better really soon.
And if you wanna take on
the quest of learning a new skill
or bolstering one that you already have,
then I highly recommend diving into
a class on Skillshare,
which is today's video sponsor.
For those of you who don't know,
Skillshare is an online learning community
with thousands of classes,
covering hundreds of topics.
Everything from cooking,
to photography,
to productivity,
in graphic design.
No matter what your interests are,
no matter what you want to learn,
there's probably a class
for it on Skillshare.
I'm currently taking this class called
Simple Productivity by Greg McKeown.
He's the author of "Essentialism"
which you've probably seen
on bookstore shelves.
And if you're someone
who's easily overwhelmed
with all the responsibilities you have
and all the things you have to do in life,
and that kind of paralyzes you
from moving forward,
then I highly recommend
checking out this class
because it's really helping me strip away
all the things that don't matter
and really focus on the things that do.
And that's honestly,
my favorite thing about Skillshare classes
is that they're all
designed for real life.
So it's extremely easy
to take whatever you're
learning on Skillshare
and apply it directly
to your real life pursuits.
It's also extremely affordable,
especially when you compare it to
in-person classes and workshops.
With an annual membership,
it comes in at less than $10 a month.
So it's kind of a no-brainer.
And that's not all.
The first 1,000 of you
who click the link in
the description below,
will get 30% off an
annual premium membership.
Even if you already have
a free trial of Skillshare,
you can still take advantage of this offer
to get a full year of unlimited learning
and creative exploration.
So make sure to hit up that link,
learn something new,
explore your creativity.
And as usual,
have a great time.
If you like this video,
make sure you hit like
because when you hit like,
the algorithm says,
"Oh, this was a good video.
"I'm gonna suggest it to more people."
And that really helps me out.
And it potentially helps other people out,
especially if they need
a video like this in their life.
And if you're lurking here
and this is the billionth time
that you've seen my face,
consider subscribing.
And if you're a fan of this channel
and you say to yourself,
"Joey, I like you and everything,
"but you just don't post often enough."
Well, check out my second channel
because I post there every single week.
It's a great time.
You can post memes in the subreddit
and I react to them.
Or you can ask me questions
and I respond to them.
And it's just a hoot.
It's a fun time.
And I hope to see you over there.
Link for that will be in the description
or somewhere near my face.
Other than that,
thank you so much for watching.
And we'll catch you in the next video.
(upbeat music)